tu te demandes pourquoi tu ne peux pas
entrer dans ma tête j'ai parfois du mal
mais tôt ou tard tous les humains les
vues masque en août pas une seconde mais
il vous fallait un peu plus qu'un simple
humain vous avez tourné ces stark
s'emparer du centre
je ne comptais pas le faire et j'ai su
en voyant sa peur que le sceptre lecomte
regrets et le frais s'autodétruire
chacun crée ce qu'ils redoutent le plus
les hommes pacifique créer des machines
de guerre des envahisseurs créer les
avengers les humains créés des humains
plus petit des enfants à lui chercher le
mot juste des enfants destinés à les
supplanter à adoucir leur faim c'est la
tombe et ultime détruire les avengers
but est de sauver le monde
mais aussi accrocheurs les adultes
seront déjà disponible en achat digital
et le 30 septembre en blu ray 3d blu ray
dvd et vidéo à la demande